all right.
NOTE CONF
Oh, good.
Um, after all that weight, I'm gonna make sure I
NOTE CONF
got some water for the first time back to Oh,
this first.
NOTE CONF
I make good on my promise.
Everybody wants a little rusby pie.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
What one?
NOTE CONF
What is it?
Are you ever more in high school to the zero?
NOTE CONF
Oh, yours.
Keep on no one.
NOTE CONF
You know what?
You little by.
NOTE CONF
There you go.
You wanna look inside for the little single mode Linux
NOTE CONF
computer?
I don't know.
NOTE CONF
You might.
That's a fun project, too.
NOTE CONF
You might not, but the guy I promised I delivered.
We can run our lock compilers on them later if
NOTE CONF
we want.
We definitely can do that.
NOTE CONF
Ah, So those are the pies?
Zeros for those interested?
NOTE CONF
Yes, they're a little bit old, but they still do
everything.
NOTE CONF
They need an adapter to connect HTM.
I've got a few of them in my office.
NOTE CONF
So if you get into it and you're like, Oh,
I don't have one of these adapters.
NOTE CONF
Uh, just come grab one.
I forgot to bring them with me.
NOTE CONF
Maybe I'll bring them next week.
Ok, Ok, well, welcome back after the break, which was
NOTE CONF
only a break for some of us.
Um, so just before we left, which week was it
NOTE CONF
that we had the trouble with the exam?
Was it the last week of semester or the first
NOTE CONF
week of holidays?
Did you get caught up in that?
NOTE CONF
Yes, you did, didn't you?
Oh, no, you didn't.
NOTE CONF
You told me you were going away.
So you went to the Monday session?
NOTE CONF
Um oh, yeah, it was.
Must have been the first week of the holidays.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, we had a trouble with the exam, but those
have all been rescheduled.
NOTE CONF
So if you were in that situation and you haven't
got your rescheduling, make sure you let me know.
NOTE CONF
But some of those people should be getting rescheduled at
1130 today.
NOTE CONF
We'll see if they turn up, uh, to do their
exams.
NOTE CONF
So we'll be finishing by 1130 so that those people
can do their exams in here if any of them
NOTE CONF
turn up.
And the assignment syntax analysis assignments were released.
NOTE CONF
The results are either basically, you either got 100% or
you got 0% based on whether you managed to get
NOTE CONF
the the zip correctly built, cos that was the AL
almost the only thing that went wrong.
NOTE CONF
Some people also forgot to adjust so they could take
the scan and read parameters.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but otherwise fairly easy assignment.
Once you got the code base put together correctly, uh,
NOTE CONF
and so lots of people didn't get the code base
put together correctly.
NOTE CONF
And I think for many of you that feels unfair
because probably not feeling of you.
NOTE CONF
I think you will probably just fine.
But for the people who were like, I did all
NOTE CONF
this work and then it was just something in my
submission that went wrong.
NOTE CONF
Just reflect upon that assignment.
That assignment was extremely easy.
NOTE CONF
Once you got your code structured correctly, the job of
that assignment was to get your code structured correctly.
NOTE CONF
So you didn't There wasn't actually much else besides getting
the code structured correctly After that, it was just like
NOTE CONF
a couple of little changes here and there.
Boom.
NOTE CONF
Done.
So for those of you who made those code changes
NOTE CONF
correctly but didn't get your code structured correctly, it is
entirely appropriate that the grade is very low because that
NOTE CONF
was the primary outcome for that assignment.
So make sure you get that sorted for the next
NOTE CONF
one because there's another one coming up and the assignment
submission and instructions are exactly the same.
NOTE CONF
We just changed the word syntax into the word translation.
Uh, so I've already been answering lots of emails to
NOTE CONF
try and help people understand what they did wrong last
time, so they don't do it again.
NOTE CONF
But there's also, uh, double checking in your workshop classes,
uh, to try and work out what you did wrong.
NOTE CONF
If you're in that boat, bring your stuff along and
show your workshop tutor and go.
NOTE CONF
Well, it looked like it worked on my computer.
What did I do wrong?
NOTE CONF
And I'll find something.
Uh, so far, the things we've found is that people
NOTE CONF
are putting it into a zip file, but not in
a syntax directory.
NOTE CONF
Then they're getting tricked when they unzip it because they're
using the wrong unzip instruction.
NOTE CONF
Not the one we gave them.
Uh, those are the primary primary troubles.
NOTE CONF
Does anybody have any questions besides the ones in my
inbox at the moment about the exam?
NOTE CONF
Uh, sorry.
The assignment.
NOTE CONF
Syntax assignment?
No.
NOTE CONF
OK, so let's do a little preview of the next
assignment.
NOTE CONF
which I will also, uh, because we've got a question
already a very good question.
NOTE CONF
And so I'm just gonna add a draught at the
top here for the next couple of days so that
NOTE CONF
people don't get confused in case things change over the
next couple of days.
NOTE CONF
Cos as we've noticed by now, uh, programming language, semantics
in particular is got lots of corner cases.
NOTE CONF
And I don't explain all the corner cases in this
translation example.
NOTE CONF
But a couple of people, I expect people to say
to me, Oh, what's gonna happen in this corner case?
NOTE CONF
What's gonna happen in this corner case and I'll expand
it where needed, Or I will I will say, you
NOTE CONF
know, that's that.
Just put that down as an error.
NOTE CONF
It's a runtime error.
It's a compiled time error.
NOTE CONF
Mhm.
But the first question is a good one, and it's
NOTE CONF
actually just me, uh, messing up something in the spec.
So I thought it would be really useful to go
NOTE CONF
through that today so I can show you my logic
for the answer to this question, cos it might answer
NOTE CONF
a bunch of other questions that you'll have as you
go through it, but let's preview the assignment, so we're
NOTE CONF
after.
Translation.
NOTE CONF
Basically, this goes to the end of week 10 material.
So we are talking about having control, flow, working and
NOTE CONF
having the basics of the first half of the functions
working so you can start working on it now.
NOTE CONF
But we're only doing control flow this week, and we're
doing functions next week, so you'll have to work, at
NOTE CONF
least on, uh, the Read and Rand you should be
able to do right now with everything you've got and
NOTE CONF
then implementing new built in functions you wouldn't be able
to.
NOTE CONF
Well, you'll read ahead.
If you want to do that before next week and
NOTE CONF
implementing a new type of loop you can do after
the discussion this week.
NOTE CONF
It's in this order because actually implementing the new type
of loop is a harder job than the implementing The
NOTE CONF
functions made that relatively simple so that once you've done
that material next Monday, it's not a giant job for
NOTE CONF
you, Then to to finish that off and get the
assignments submitted on time for the 20th.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but in short, we're making sure read and rend
run on our com com interpreter When you run when
NOTE CONF
the read command occurs, you should stop and ask for
input from the user.
NOTE CONF
And when the Rand command occurs, you should pick a
pseudo random number.
NOTE CONF
Uh, we're doing very pseudo random, as in not random
at all, because if it was random, we wouldn't be
NOTE CONF
able to automatically grade your assignments cos we wouldn't know
what the output of your assignments should be.
NOTE CONF
It could be any random number.
So for the purposes of this assignment, the random number
NOTE CONF
is each of these numbers one in a row, 57
the first time, 97 the second time, and so on
NOTE CONF
and so forth.
So let's see if I can get a demo of
NOTE CONF
that up and running.
I think I've got a solution somewhere that I could
NOTE CONF
run to show you, but I definitely got a solution
somewhere.
NOTE CONF
OK, so as before, you gotta unzip it so that
I can do the JACC translation star dot java.
NOTE CONF
Um, once again, I'm not running your a ST tool
generator, so you run that yourself and you make sure
NOTE CONF
that the EX PR dot java and the STMT dot
java are in the form you need and you submit
NOTE CONF
those forms.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
Nods and shakes for things that are making head sense.
Otherwise, nothing's making sense.
NOTE CONF
OK, uh, so I will compile yours like that, and
then I will run yours like this.
NOTE CONF
Same as before.
Ah, but this time we don't have that extra parameter
NOTE CONF
for the read or pa the scan or par section.
We're just doing straight up the file.
NOTE CONF
I've got some example files of my own in here.
So if I look at one of the re files,
NOTE CONF
uh, you can see what I'm wanting your compiler to
do here.
NOTE CONF
I, I the explanation.
I don't give you a copy of my compiler, cos
NOTE CONF
you could de compile it.
Um, you've got the explanation in the text, but I'll,
NOTE CONF
I'll show it to you here while I can.
Um, so when when it hits the read command, I
NOTE CONF
should just bring that file up, we're gonna find it.
We're gonna find it.
NOTE CONF
Maybe not computers really struggling today.
It's like that, But I couldn't find it.
NOTE CONF
We got it.
So this is what this programme that I'm running right
NOTE CONF
now is, except that's not working.
Oh, sorry.
NOTE CONF
Print high plus read.
Uh, so this is one point where the semantics gets
NOTE CONF
interesting.
So I I've written a longer programme.
NOTE CONF
It's got a wild loop in it because we're further
along now, right?
NOTE CONF
Print high, plus read.
So read has to stop to ask for the input
NOTE CONF
from the user.
So one of the things that is built into locks,
NOTE CONF
uh, even though you don't realise it yet is that
the arguments to a function have to be executed before
NOTE CONF
the function can be a This is a command.
The arguments to this special built in command have to
NOTE CONF
be calculated before the special command is run.
So I don't get high printed on the screen yet
NOTE CONF
I just get the re call happening, the re operation
and the read operation says stop and ask for user
NOTE CONF
input.
So it does.
NOTE CONF
It stops, asks for input, I type something and press
enter and then it completes the rest of the programme.
NOTE CONF
So the rest of the programme is finishing up that
line there, so it prints it.
NOTE CONF
Then it reads another line from me and puts it
in a variable way.
NOTE CONF
So it's stopped and asked again for another piece of
text from me and I give it.
NOTE CONF
And then it runs the rest of the script.
And the rest of the script is it makes a
NOTE CONF
new string called Attaching a New string called Gap, and
it loops around 10 times putting the word attaching on
NOTE CONF
the end of the word that I gave it.
So I end up with start attaching it to that.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
So that's deeper into the semantics of read now.
NOTE CONF
And there's a couple of things that have come out,
You know, exactly what does it look like to ask
NOTE CONF
for user input?
It looks like input required, uh, pointy parenthesis space.
NOTE CONF
When does it happen?
It happens at the evaluation of the read node.
NOTE CONF
Um, and so in you've been given an example programme
as well.
NOTE CONF
So you've got red dot locks read dot out and
read dot Input in an example.
NOTE CONF
Zip file for you.
And so, if you can see that, uh, that P
NOTE CONF
doesn't need to be there.
Um, but it doesn't break the programme.
NOTE CONF
You can see that for the input I just gave
you there.
NOTE CONF
The out file shows you what that output should be,
and so you wanna make sure that yours matches that
NOTE CONF
easy enough?
Uh, very important, because we're entirely marking automatically.
NOTE CONF
This time.
The rubric should make that clear.
NOTE CONF
We just pump it through results match, get the mark.
So that's Reed And then Rand, So we've got a
NOTE CONF
ra dot locks as well.
So here.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna print, uh, for some reason, I printed 10
plus the first random numbers.
NOTE CONF
Goodness knows why, but, um, I'm gonna go around in
the loop, and I'm gonna ask for a random number,
NOTE CONF
and I'm gonna print 10.
Plus that ran, ran, ran, ran, ran.
NOTE CONF
So this should print 10 random numbers with 10 added
to them, and it does.
NOTE CONF
But what I hope to see is that it's my
random numbers, because I random doesn't really mean random random
NOTE CONF
means take from that list.
And if we go back and check the list, the
NOTE CONF
list was 57 97 28 7, 71.
And so yes, I'm getting what I want.
NOTE CONF
The random list has 12 numbers in it.
If I ask for the 13th random number, go back
NOTE CONF
and give me 57 again.
But I'm not going to cos I'm not trying to
NOTE CONF
be nasty.
OK, cool.
NOTE CONF
So that you can get going on.
You're just writing the interpreter part for the stuff you
NOTE CONF
did in the first assignment.
Now there were lots of people who found easy little
NOTE CONF
tricks, and I got no problems with that easy little
tricks for matching what I needed for assignment one.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but to give you a stronger base to work
off, I provided my example.
NOTE CONF
Solution for the syntax assignment.
Um, that's Week five code, though.
NOTE CONF
So I took the Week five code.
I added the solution for the syntax assignment, and there
NOTE CONF
it is.
That's a long way from what you can use in
NOTE CONF
the second assignment, cos the second assignment's gotta have the
translations gotta have all through to the Week 10 code.
NOTE CONF
Otherwise, you won't be able to run my loops, and
you won't be able to do any built in functions
NOTE CONF
at all, and you won't be able to do variables
and everything else, But it shows you how to go
NOTE CONF
from week five to solution.
So you can roll that solution into your own say,
NOTE CONF
week 10 code that you'll eventually get to.
But I don't use that as a starting point for
NOTE CONF
your assignment, because all you're doing is giving yourself lots
of work to get that up to scratch with variables
NOTE CONF
and everything else.
You should already have someone on your computer from last
NOTE CONF
week's material.
And then from this week's material, you should have something
NOTE CONF
that's able to do everything except the built in functions
from this week's material.
NOTE CONF
So we're doing, um, control flow today and we'll do
conditions, wires and UH, four loops.
NOTE CONF
So we're introducing a new type of loop, which automatically
loops across all the characters in a string.
NOTE CONF
And we have to think about the semantics of locks
against Locks.
NOTE CONF
Doesn't have characters.
So what does it mean to loop across?
NOTE CONF
Uh, the characters of a string?
Well, it means to take each single character one at
NOTE CONF
a time as a string.
So we got the string that's the same the just
NOTE CONF
the first character, then the string.
That's the second character, uh, And so, for example, if
NOTE CONF
I wanna go around this whole string and print it,
all it does is do character by character, and co
NOTE CONF
print always creates a new line.
That's what my output is gonna be.
NOTE CONF
So you've got to implement that new control flow from
go to O.
NOTE CONF
That means all the new syntactic forms for the scanner,
the new passing rule that I've given you the passing
NOTE CONF
rule.
You just have to convert that into code.
NOTE CONF
Um, and then the interpretation of that as well in
the interpreter.
NOTE CONF
So that'll be an exact copy of what we're doing
this week.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and again, there's examples in the the zip file.
When it comes to errors, we won't be testing lots
NOTE CONF
of error conditions, but we will be testing the passing
of your for loop of your string loop.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
Um, so we've got an example in the zip file
NOTE CONF
of what errors should look like.
So, um, for example, on my input here, which is
NOTE CONF
a broken string loop, doesn't match the syntax, cos I
said it had to have a V here where the
NOTE CONF
S goes.
Um, the real loop should look like that LVS in
NOTE CONF
whatever, but this one's got just loop in.
Um, I've given you an example of what we're expecting
NOTE CONF
that error to be, and that's a standard locks error
just coming out of the locks.
NOTE CONF
Parsa You don't have to do anything fancy to get
it.
NOTE CONF
Um, but I wanna make sure that you haven't messed
up.
NOTE CONF
Other parts of the Los pas are in the process,
so I haven't done something really weird to get there.
NOTE CONF
But we will only check the very first line of
the error, Not any following lines.
NOTE CONF
Um, because you know how Locks tries to the when
you when Rice discovers a parser error, it tries to
NOTE CONF
synchronise again and go again.
And Ma and pa further in the programme.
NOTE CONF
So that's where the 2nd and 3rd and 4th errors
can come from.
NOTE CONF
We're not checking those when we give you an example
error programme.
NOTE CONF
We're only checking the first line to see that that
matches, but it does have to match.
NOTE CONF
Exactly.
So we've given you an example of that.
NOTE CONF
And then finally, when we get to functions next week,
we'll be doing it in two separate parts function calls
NOTE CONF
we will do next week and function definitions.
We'll do the week after cos there's quite a lot
NOTE CONF
just in getting your head around function calls in locks,
um, and the way we can test that and the
NOTE CONF
way we do it in the book as well is
that put a few built in functions in?
NOTE CONF
They're not defined by the user.
Uh, he puts in clock to to work out how
NOTE CONF
long since the programme started running so you can start
timing your programmes.
NOTE CONF
We'll add two others floor and subs string as global
functions, and then you'll have some programmes that exercise those
NOTE CONF
global functions.
No need for the user to define their own functions.
NOTE CONF
That's Week 11 material.
You don't have time to get that done before the
NOTE CONF
assignment's due.
And the question that came up in the Forum, which
NOTE CONF
I'll go through now, is an inconsistency here that I
wanted to that we'll we'll see when we get into
NOTE CONF
it.
But before I do that, are there any questions?
NOTE CONF
Did I say 1230 after the normal lecture?
What?
NOTE CONF
Uh man, I guess I'm here till 1230 then.
Ok, um send me the email.
NOTE CONF
OK, but if I've told people 1230 I will be
here at 1230.
NOTE CONF
Ok, so that's a question on that.
I probably told accidentally told one or two people 1230
NOTE CONF
everybody else 1130.
I keep messing that up in my head.
NOTE CONF
For some reason, I feel like the three hour lecture
goes to one o'clock, but it doesn't.
NOTE CONF
It only goes to 12 o'clock.
Um, OK, that's a bummer.
NOTE CONF
OK, so no questions on the assignment, then?
No.
NOTE CONF
All right, let's have a look at this question that
came up in the form Very good person who asked
NOTE CONF
it.
It's a good question asked clearly, and I can answer
NOTE CONF
it clearly.
So the assignment description it mentions that floor returns results
NOTE CONF
like 5.0 or 12.0 so floor is a function that
just takes away the decimal point.
NOTE CONF
And I said, OK, the output should look like 5.0
or minus 12 point.
NOTE CONF
Oh, but in my example, programme for floor, the output
was not 0.0.
NOTE CONF
It was just nought.
And so that's inconsistent.
NOTE CONF
So what did I mean?
All right, let's find out what I should have meant.
NOTE CONF
So the answer is that this is what my implementation
does.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and this is what my theoretically, I think the
answer should be, uh so which one should I go
NOTE CONF
with?
I'm probably gonna go with the theoretical one but I
NOTE CONF
want to explore a bit more to just explain why
I would go with that one.
NOTE CONF
What we're getting into here is, uh, how to resolve
the semantics of a programming language that you're writing.
NOTE CONF
So the key here is Well, what kind of numbers
does lock have?
NOTE CONF
Just doubles?
Lock only has doubles.
NOTE CONF
So normally, a function like floor would take in a
double and get back an integer.
NOTE CONF
But that's not gonna make any sense in locks, is
it?
NOTE CONF
It's gonna take in a double and give back a
double, but that double is not gonna have any decimal
NOTE CONF
point left anymore.
So my question really is I.
NOTE CONF
I want this to be consistent with what locks would
otherwise do.
NOTE CONF
So the question here is not Well, the question is,
what's Matt's answer?
NOTE CONF
But Matt's answer is, well, whatever locks would normally do.
So let's explore what locks would normally do.
NOTE CONF
So if I run this without that, if I print
4.5 locks, prints 4.5 if I print four locks principle,
NOTE CONF
OK, so when I am taking when I'm taking the
decimal point off something, Locks doesn't print it out for
NOTE CONF
me.
I don't think, but let's try something else.
NOTE CONF
Let's try.
Oops.
NOTE CONF
There you go.
So now it's consistent, right?
NOTE CONF
As long as the number I get back in locks
is a whole number, it will print it without any
NOTE CONF
decimal place.
So that's the behaviour I want for my floor function.
NOTE CONF
I wanted to output something without a decimal place, so
I wanna make the adjustment over here.
NOTE CONF
Um, I wanna say in this case, O, let's edit.
I wanna reply.
NOTE CONF
Stay internally.
Consistent.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
Thank you.
NOTE CONF
And that means I go back over to the spec
and I adjust it as well.
NOTE CONF
So that was here.
And we hit the settings and OK, there we go.
NOTE CONF
So thank you for that question.
There's a clarification.
NOTE CONF
Uh, does that make sense?
That makes sense.
NOTE CONF
What should we get into this week's material, then?
Yes, Let's get into the sweets material.
NOTE CONF
Uh, let's see if I got an answer from that
person.
NOTE CONF
So listen, we don't need that.
We don't need that.
NOTE CONF
We need this.
OK, so we've been working.
NOTE CONF
We made it to the point where we have what?
Where have we made it?
NOTE CONF
To the point of we got variables.
I think that's what we got.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, At the end of last week, we've just done
basically three weeks making sure we could get statements into
NOTE CONF
the code and keeping track of those statements and having
environments.
NOTE CONF
So he worked out how to use environments to store
the state of all the variables and to nest environments
NOTE CONF
so that you could go back to a previous environment
when you got inside a new block.
NOTE CONF
So now we're gonna look at control flow, and he's
got the word syntactic sugar there because we're gonna do
NOTE CONF
our first bit.
Well, we've actually done our first bit of syntactic sugar
NOTE CONF
already.
Uh, we did it at the scanning phase.
NOTE CONF
We had sugar for the Reed and Rand.
We had the double bang and the double, uh, in
NOTE CONF
the backward arrow, but that that's sugar implemented at the
syntactic level.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna do sugar implemented at the semantic level now,
so reminder what I mean by sugar.
NOTE CONF
Semantic sugar means any programming language feature that I can
explain in terms of another programming language feature.
NOTE CONF
So instead of saying, you know, Y loops and four
loops are different things, and the compiler treats them differently.
NOTE CONF
I might just say the compiler just turns a for
loop into a Y loop and then moves on, so
NOTE CONF
the only thing it really needs to know about is
a Y loop.
NOTE CONF
It knows about a four loop so that it can
pass it and then convert it to a Y loop,
NOTE CONF
and then it forgets they even exist and just moves
on.
NOTE CONF
Syntactic sugar is a great way to have a language
with lots of features, but still a small core because
NOTE CONF
the more features you add to the core of a
language, the more convoluted everything gets with their interactions.
NOTE CONF
And so the more often you can explain a feature
just as syntactic sugar in terms of something else that's
NOTE CONF
already in the language, the easier it is for your
programmers to get their head around what you're doing.
NOTE CONF
The the number of core things they need to keep
in their head is smaller, and the number the number
NOTE CONF
of things you can reasonably add to your compiler gets
bigger because you don't have to make those changes all
NOTE CONF
the way through the compiler slash interpreter.
You can do it just just up until the passing
NOTE CONF
phase, convert it at that stage and move on.
So we're gonna see that for the four loops in
NOTE CONF
locks.
But for the wild loops, Well, obviously there's when we
NOTE CONF
first hit loops the first loop we implement, we have
nothing we can convert it into.
NOTE CONF
So we're gonna have to implement it from scratch.
Yes.
NOTE CONF
This is an interesting point.
Uh, at this point, once we've added conditional statements or
NOTE CONF
control flow to our language, we have a complete programming
language, a language that can do anything any other language
NOTE CONF
can do.
And so the phrase for that is, uh, T incomplete.
NOTE CONF
And so we get a little theoretical discussion here about
where that comes from.
NOTE CONF
So, uh, Well, what he says here is pretty good
in the early part of the last century.
NOTE CONF
So we're talking about 20th century 1900 through to about
1920 mathematicians stumbled into a series of confusing paradoxes, and
NOTE CONF
those paradoxes came from an attempt to formalise mathematics from
the ground up.
NOTE CONF
To say, mathematics must be a fundamental thing about the
universe.
NOTE CONF
And so I should just be able to take this
small set of things and build and build and build
NOTE CONF
until I have all of mathematics, only ever building on
things that are already proven by other things.
NOTE CONF
And they hit a crisis cos they every time they
attempted that they hit, uh, paradoxes.
NOTE CONF
Um oh, So they've gone back and tried this via
logic.
NOTE CONF
So they've set a bunch of axioms and defined a
logic and hoped that they could then define mathematics on
NOTE CONF
top of an impervious foundation that way.
Um, so if you do it via set theory, you
NOTE CONF
fail because of Russell's paradox.
And if you do it via logic, you fail because
NOTE CONF
of Ma.
What's the what's the short way to say it?
NOTE CONF
You basically you fail because of computing?
Um, yeah.
NOTE CONF
So this is one way to I'm probably a mangling
it a little bit, but, you know, it's not a
NOTE CONF
history lesson.
So if you think I want to redefine mathematics and
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna start from sets, you end up hitting Russell's
paradox and going, That's no good.
NOTE CONF
I can't go any further.
And so you go all right.
NOTE CONF
Starting from scratch, I'm not gonna use sets.
I'm gonna use logic as the basis, uh, and when
NOTE CONF
you do that, you very quickly.
Well, they not very quickly, but through very smart people,
NOTE CONF
I found that, uh, logics may never halt.
Deciding the truth or or false falseness of a logical
NOTE CONF
statement is input.
And so sets are constructed.
NOTE CONF
Logics are much more computed.
Uh, and so in the process of understanding logics, they
NOTE CONF
they they basically invented computation.
I wouldn't really say invented, but you get what I
NOTE CONF
mean.
Um, computation in the 19 thirties and forties was just
NOTE CONF
the mechanical application of logic.
And then, uh, one of the logics that was created
NOTE CONF
was called the Lambda Calculus specifically focused on the calculation,
uh, approach to it.
NOTE CONF
And the laic characters had the paradox that it was
impossible to know whether a logical statement had a true
NOTE CONF
or false answer just by mechanical means.
And that broke it all again and they went, Oh,
NOTE CONF
jeez, we're stuck again.
But in the process, they went, Hang on this lambda
NOTE CONF
calculus, which is basically just computing anything that can be
computed.
NOTE CONF
That sounds cool.
This was all before computers existed.
NOTE CONF
Uh, and the Lambda Calculus was a theoretical construct.
You couldn't actually build a Lambda calculus machine, but it
NOTE CONF
was created by Alonso Church.
And, uh, he's a mathematician at Was he at Stanford
NOTE CONF
at the time, or somewhere in the US?
Uh, and one of his PhD students was Alan Turing.
NOTE CONF
Who's the one you have heard of?
Because Alan Turing built a machine that worked equivalently to
NOTE CONF
the Lambda Calculus but could be built in real life,
And that was the chewing machine.
NOTE CONF
And then he went in to use that machine or
something like that machine to crack codes because it could
NOTE CONF
do computations faster than humans could do it.
You know, once you could turn the computational thing into
NOTE CONF
a machine and you could crank the handle faster and
off you go.
NOTE CONF
So the key thing about a Turing machine is that
it's exactly the same as a Lambda calculus but can
NOTE CONF
physically be built.
So these these twin things, these Lambda calculus and chewing
NOTE CONF
machines are the core of computation, and as long as
anything else you build along the way is equivalent to
NOTE CONF
either or both of those, then it can also compute
everything that can be computed.
NOTE CONF
And the key to getting to a lamp to a
chewing machine is having an infinite amount of memory that
NOTE CONF
you can read and write, and the control flow can
be changed depending on what's in the memory.
NOTE CONF
That's really the three things.
So a chewing machine is considered as a big, infinitely
NOTE CONF
long tape with symbols written on it, and you read
a symbol.
NOTE CONF
And based on what you read, you move and you
write another symbol.
NOTE CONF
So it's the reading, the writing and the based on
what you read.
NOTE CONF
Which direction do you move?
That's all you need.
NOTE CONF
So for us as programmers, as soon as we introduce
variables we've got reading and writing, we can pretend our
NOTE CONF
memory is infinite.
And then once we can read from the memory and
NOTE CONF
make a decision about where to go next, which is
what an if statement is or a loop is.
NOTE CONF
We've got a chewing machine, so it's just variables.
And if statements is absolutely everything you need, so any
NOTE CONF
programming language you know of that has variables.
And if statements is true and complete, and a bunch
NOTE CONF
of others as well, because there are other ways to
reach you in completeness, OK, very cool and left out
NOTE CONF
of this part.
But what I think is interesting is that, um after
NOTE CONF
Turing came another.
So there were three, primary geniuses in the creation of
NOTE CONF
of programming.
Number one was Alonzo Church who did it?
NOTE CONF
Theoretically, Number two was Alan Turing, who built the machine,
and number three was von Neumann in the US, who
NOTE CONF
Well, he made an adjustment to the machine to make
it practical.
NOTE CONF
But also, he was a bit of a superstar scientist.
So whatever von Neumann was doing, everyone else wanted to
NOTE CONF
do as well.
And so when Von von Neumann got into computing machines,
NOTE CONF
everyone got into computing machines.
He was one of the Manhattan Project dudes.
NOTE CONF
But you need all three of those.
And so, in fact, these computers that we work with
NOTE CONF
now should really be called von Neumann machines, not chewing
machines cos they have a special feature that he introduced,
NOTE CONF
but whatever, whatever.
That's just history.
NOTE CONF
So conditional execution.
I mean, you know this.
NOTE CONF
It feels a bit weird in this course, right?
Cos you're going deeper and it's a third year course,
NOTE CONF
and it's a capstone course.
And I'm like, Now I'm gonna explain to you what
NOTE CONF
an if statement is.
But you know what an if statement is, but we're
NOTE CONF
getting more at the edges of what an if statement
is and precisely what an If statement is, uh, so
NOTE CONF
these statements, we're used to say if and parentheses and
a condition and then some curly braces and off you
NOTE CONF
go, you might be familiar with the turnery operator, which
I think both C and Java have.
NOTE CONF
Um, the turny operator is specific.
Well, is there because if and if statement is a
NOTE CONF
statement, um, it's nice to have an if expression as
well.
NOTE CONF
And the turny operator is the if expression and the
normal one is the if statement so well, what does
NOTE CONF
that think to yourself?
What that means right now if I write a bit
NOTE CONF
of code.
So the difference between statement and expression, right?
NOTE CONF
You know, statements just do things and have side effects
and expressions return values.
NOTE CONF
OK, but what what happens quite a lot of the
time is that you've got some variable called Y, and
NOTE CONF
you want it to be equal to something.
You don't know what you want it to be equal
NOTE CONF
to until you've looked at a different variable.
So let's say I want Y to be empty if
NOTE CONF
X is zero and non empty.
If X is not zero, just a string, right?
NOTE CONF
So I might do something like this.
Well, don't know yet.
NOTE CONF
And then I'll say, If X equals one, I'll say
Y equals empty.
NOTE CONF
And otherwise, I'll say Y equals not empty.
Easy enough.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
But what's happening here is that I'm really just trying
NOTE CONF
to fill in this expression based on, uh uh conditionals
somewhere.
NOTE CONF
So having a conditional statement is awkward because I have
to write.
NOTE CONF
I have to set up Y to be something, then
do two different sets to set it when really, all
NOTE CONF
I wanted was something like VY equals empty.
Oh, and I want something that says, I want it
NOTE CONF
to be the value on the left or the value
on the right rather than the statement on the left
NOTE CONF
or the statement on the right.
It's a much nicer way to write it, but in
NOTE CONF
that case, this is an conditional expression, or this is
a conditional statement, and that's what the Turnery operator ends
NOTE CONF
up being.
And because I don't use the turnery operator enough, I
NOTE CONF
can't remember the syntax, but I think it's something like
the real syntax is something like, Maybe this No, it's
NOTE CONF
the other one, probably something like that.
It's got the conditional and then the the value that
NOTE CONF
it is untrue and then the value that it is
un false.
NOTE CONF
But key there is that it's sitting a different slot
in my abstract syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
It's when I need an expression and I've got a
condition.
NOTE CONF
Have you ever heard of an expression based loop?
No, you haven't because it wouldn't really make sense.
NOTE CONF
What would an expression based loop evaluate to cos loops
go over many, many times?
NOTE CONF
Would it evaluate to the first answer?
The second answer.
NOTE CONF
All of the answers jammed together that that has to
be answered, but with a condition.
NOTE CONF
It's always one of two things, so it's an easier
thing to put into an expression form.
NOTE CONF
In fact, there are expression based loops.
Um, that's what those blocks and things were in ruby,
NOTE CONF
and they were always returning lists of things.
So when you have an expression based loop, it doesn't
NOTE CONF
just return a single thing, it will return a whole
list of things for you.
NOTE CONF
So in expression based languages, it's fine to have loops,
but they'll always return the list.
NOTE CONF
But in these more statement based languages, where we're used
to variables just holding single things, we can get ourselves
NOTE CONF
to a expression based condition, but not necessarily.
But anyway, there you go, that's that's a little bit
NOTE CONF
more internally.
And why is it called Dony?
NOTE CONF
Just because it's an operator with three arguments and it's
not really a single operator, It looks like two separate
NOTE CONF
operators, but you need that when you've got turnery.
Cos you gotta separate the bits, but it's really a
NOTE CONF
single operator taking three arguments.
And so if we were doing another language like IO,
NOTE CONF
we might do something like won't affect any language.
But it's always possible to turn an operator into a
NOTE CONF
function right.
You just have to switch syntax.
NOTE CONF
An operator is really just a function with different syntax.
Um, so when you've got functions with two arguments, the
NOTE CONF
new syntax is obvious.
You just put the the the operator in between.
NOTE CONF
But when you've got functions with three arguments, the new
syntax is less obvious.
NOTE CONF
You end up doing funny things like this up here,
but I want you to start getting that idea in
NOTE CONF
your head as well of operators and functions being completely
equivalent.
NOTE CONF
And we just use the term operator when we're syntactically
doing one thing.
NOTE CONF
And we use the term function when we're syntactically doing
another thing now.
NOTE CONF
We saw that when we did the Scala code, right,
because we were just watch switching in between operators and
NOTE CONF
in that case, methods.
Operators are methods back and forth with just one S
NOTE CONF
syntactic sugar rule that Scarlett gave us.
All right, So what does an what does it look
NOTE CONF
like to put an if statement into the programming language?
Well, we it's another kind of statement, So it just
NOTE CONF
goes in where all the other statements are and the
syntax is pretty simple.
NOTE CONF
It's a if keyword, which we were already collecting.
It's the parenthesis syntax, which we were already collecting.
NOTE CONF
And then what goes inside that condition is any expression
whatsoever, not a statement, an expression.
NOTE CONF
And then what goes after that is any statement whatsoever.
And because we have blocked statements in our language, remember
NOTE CONF
that in our language this is a statement.
It's a variable declaration statement, but this is also a
NOTE CONF
statement We've got the syntax for that.
That's a block statement.
NOTE CONF
We don't need to capture the curly braces in the
PAS rules here.
NOTE CONF
By not capturing the curly braces, we're allowing two different
forms.
NOTE CONF
We're allowing the form.
If X equals zero, Y equals empty because that's if
NOTE CONF
keyword parenthesis, expression, parenthesis, statement.
That's correct.
NOTE CONF
And we're also allowing this one because the Curly Brace
one is a statement as well.
NOTE CONF
And that just gets us to form when we used
to.
NOTE CONF
Yes, only it has to be a statement, but we
do have expression statements, right?
NOTE CONF
So because we've got a passing form that will pass
just an expression into a statement.
NOTE CONF
Yes, that's fine.
But it's only because we've got that OK, and then
NOTE CONF
optionally after all of that, you can have an L
keyword and a statement with it.
NOTE CONF
OK, so that's our syntax rule.
We're gonna Well, we we've seen that we don't always
NOTE CONF
need a new abstract syntax tree node for every edition
we make, but in this case, we definitely are.
NOTE CONF
So the new abstract syntax tree rule we have to
put in is the if rule.
NOTE CONF
Now it's gonna have to have Children of the node
for all of the things inside it.
NOTE CONF
And there are three things inside it.
One expression, one statement and optionally another statement.
NOTE CONF
So we capture all three of those the expression the
then branch and the branch.
NOTE CONF
And then finally, we gotta actually do the parsing for
it again.
NOTE CONF
This is a statement where, as with all of our
statements in locks, let's jump up to some other locks
NOTE CONF
code that was doing something.
As in all of our statements in locks, they declare
NOTE CONF
themselves with their very first token.
We're never left wondering what's what's this statement gonna be?
NOTE CONF
If there's a print token, it's a print.
If there's a V token, it's a declaration.
NOTE CONF
Um, if there's an identifier, then we're doing an assignment.
And in this case, if there's an if statement, we're
NOTE CONF
doing the if so, they're very nice and easy to
pass.
NOTE CONF
Oops, so so over here.
We just in our Parsa right at the very top.
NOTE CONF
We just go look, if you've declared yourself an if
statement, then go use the if statement Parsa and that
NOTE CONF
works like all the others.
OK, the if statement pasa has already consumed the if
NOTE CONF
so it just has to consume the left parenthesis.
Then it has to consume the expression inside and then
NOTE CONF
the right parenthesis.
And then it consumes.
NOTE CONF
Definitely one statement, and it might be a single statement
or a block of many together.
NOTE CONF
But it doesn't matter.
It's still just a single call to the statement, Parsa.
NOTE CONF
And if the statement passer sees a curly brace, it
goes into this block one.
NOTE CONF
And if it doesn't see a curly brace, it just
grabs the one and then optionally.
NOTE CONF
After that, there'll be an L.
So we set up the L to be now and
NOTE CONF
then.
If there is an keyword, we go, OK, well, well,
NOTE CONF
let's pass the branch and we'll store that as well.
We need to give put null in it to start
NOTE CONF
with because we always have to give the a ST.
No, it's branch, even if there's nothing in there.
NOTE CONF
And then we return the new a ST.
A statement conditioned then by cranch.
NOTE CONF
So, um, we did this trick last time where I
was projecting this onto my computer.
NOTE CONF
But I forgot how we did that.
How did we do that?
NOTE CONF
Does anyone remember?
I think I was just aeroplane to my computer.
NOTE CONF
I'll try it.
But I didn't like doing that.
NOTE CONF
What?
BD a play?
NOTE CONF
I don't think I'm SI FVFJD.
Whatever.
NOTE CONF
But it's the only computer I see here, huh?
That's what I am.
NOTE CONF
OK, what was I about to do?
Well, I'm gonna show you the a ST node that
NOTE CONF
we passed that into.
So let's do an example.
NOTE CONF
Um, we'll do a a one with a bit more
going on in it.
NOTE CONF
So it'll be VX equals three.
If X equals zero, X equals three.
NOTE CONF
So we're just determined to make X equals three, no
matter what.
NOTE CONF
S you with a bit of code.
So how's this gonna pass as it goes through our
NOTE CONF
Parsa?
So the parser will pass a bunch of statements and
NOTE CONF
so we can think ahead and see that it's gonna
pass that statement and that statement.
NOTE CONF
So when it passes the first statement, it's gonna notice
that it's a V and it's going to go into
NOTE CONF
the VA decal, and that's going to help it work
out that it turns into a V Dele.
NOTE CONF
Uh, So again, by the way, this is me showing
you, uh, one way to trace through what's going on.
NOTE CONF
So we're gonna get a var Deco.
That's why I hated it, because I didn't have my
NOTE CONF
other thing in front of me.
And I literally can't remember exactly what the VAR Deco
NOTE CONF
looks like because there's too much going on.
I have to go back to the code to check
NOTE CONF
it, but let's just let's just roll with it.
So this one creates a V decal, a ST node.
NOTE CONF
If someone's got the A ST in front of them,
they can tell me what I'm getting wrong.
NOTE CONF
So it creates a VA decal, a ST node and
the VA decal, I think had a token and an
NOTE CONF
expression.
Can someone get open the the STMT dot java on
NOTE CONF
their computer?
Who's gonna do that?
NOTE CONF
Nobody.
It's all happening today.
NOTE CONF
No, one of these people with a computer already is.
Come on, who's got who's got STMT dot Java open?
NOTE CONF
Have you got it?
Hm?
NOTE CONF
You don't have.
Can you open it for me?
NOTE CONF
SDMT dot Java?
So that's one of the a ST nodes we generated.
NOTE CONF
There's a point to this as well, by the way,
which is, if you're trying to understand this without having
NOTE CONF
a copy of the compiler next to you and reflecting
back and forth.
NOTE CONF
You're probably not properly understanding.
It's perfectly OK to be someone who likes to write
NOTE CONF
things on a notebook and then go back to the
code.
NOTE CONF
But you know, there's there's too much to remember in
your head about how this compiler works.
NOTE CONF
You have to use the you have to use the
existing implementation you have as a reference to build off.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
And so, uh, if we look up the VA decal
NOTE CONF
class What?
What?
NOTE CONF
Um what Two arguments?
Does it constructor Take, uh, name and initialise.
NOTE CONF
So that's what they were called.
OK, so that one's called name and initialise.
NOTE CONF
Thank you.
A name is a token, right?
NOTE CONF
Initialise as an expression.
Exactly.
NOTE CONF
So this is a token, and tokens just have a
A name.
NOTE CONF
So this one's X and initialise.
It is an expression.
NOTE CONF
So which kind of expression is it?
It's gonna be a literal expression.
NOTE CONF
And if you look up literal expression and expression dot
Java, you'll probably find that it's just gotta a three.
NOTE CONF
OK, so pausing that first line has created this, So
that's our first statement.
NOTE CONF
So what's pausing?
The second statement gonna do?
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna move all this out the way.
So what's pas in the second statement gonna make So
NOTE CONF
according to the book, it's making this new node called
the If Statement.
NOTE CONF
I think it just said if if you look, you
won't have it in your statement, Dava, cos you're not
NOTE CONF
up to date with week nine yet.
Um, but it was if and the if node had
NOTE CONF
a condition, I'm gonna write it sideways and then and
an OK, so this was our condition, and this was
NOTE CONF
our then and we didn't have an L.
So for us, the condition here and the condition has
NOTE CONF
to be an expression.
So what kind of expression is this one gonna be?
NOTE CONF
Well, it's a binary, I think.
Yes, because that's a binary operator.
NOTE CONF
And the binary operators got a token, a left and
a right, and its token is the double equals, and
NOTE CONF
its left is the variable expression X.
And it's right is the literal expression three, and the
NOTE CONF
then branch is a block statement.
And if we call a block statement has a list
NOTE CONF
of statements inside it, and so what is gonna be
the list of statements inside this block statement?
NOTE CONF
We're gonna gonna find one of them, and that's gonna
be a variable assignment.
NOTE CONF
And that variable assignment is gonna have the identifier.
I think that's probably actually identifier in there.
NOTE CONF
And the expression.
And so the identifier comes out at X and the
NOTE CONF
expression comes out at a literal.
So that's I made a mistake here.
NOTE CONF
That's not literal.
Three.
NOTE CONF
That's literal zero.
Yeah, right.
NOTE CONF
So that's our This is our abstract syntax tree that
we've got.
NOTE CONF
We've got two statements.
One of them's here.
NOTE CONF
Statement one and these are in a list.
But it's a bit hard for me to show that
NOTE CONF
right here.
And this is statement two, uh, and statement two.
NOTE CONF
Is this if, uh well, sorry.
There's one more part of this F which we haven't
NOTE CONF
filled in yet.
Which is the LS.
NOTE CONF
Oops.
The goes to null.
NOTE CONF
So we've actually got all those bits of the syntax
tree.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Does that make sense?
NOTE CONF
We happy?
No.
NOTE CONF
Shakes?
Yes, We're happy.
NOTE CONF
You do have to do this.
I think I think I said this a few times,
NOTE CONF
but I say it again.
I think you do have to draw these out, but
NOTE CONF
I think that's one of the downsides of the book
is that it doesn't draw out these abstract syntax tree
NOTE CONF
nodes for you.
And I think it's a bit hard to follow what's
NOTE CONF
going on unless you do.
Because when I come to interpret an if statement, I'm
NOTE CONF
interpreting inter interpreting exactly this tree and I'm making decisions
about how do I interpret this tree to get the
NOTE CONF
answer I want out of it.
So a reminder of what happened when we interpreted this
NOTE CONF
tree up?
Uh, how do I?
NOTE CONF
Is there a way to show what my finger is
doing on an iPad without drawing?
NOTE CONF
I don't know.
Let's try draw.
NOTE CONF
No, I don't think there is heart Stand up.
So when we were interpreting a programme, we interpreted one
NOTE CONF
second at a time, right?
So interpreting bar decal, What did that look like?
NOTE CONF
Well, interpreting bar decal looked like adding into the environment
a new X and associating it with the literal three
NOTE CONF
and then moving on.
That was all in there.
NOTE CONF
What does it mean?
Interpret the next thing?
NOTE CONF
So that's what we're gonna do next.
But let's think about it just by looking at the
NOTE CONF
tree.
I mean, we think about it as programmers.
NOTE CONF
What is what do we want this if statement to
do we want this if statement.
NOTE CONF
But ultimately we want to update the environment so that
my X definitely points to three.
NOTE CONF
It was already point to three, but that's the step
I wanted to do.
NOTE CONF
Uh, which is probably, which is this one that that's
exactly what this bit will do.
NOTE CONF
We already know that that is going to assign look
at the environment and set X three.
NOTE CONF
So the final goal, it's just the normal execution of
this part of the the code and the normal execution
NOTE CONF
of that that's already built into it is a function
I can call code.
NOTE CONF
I've already got an execute function in my interpreter, and
I can pass it a piece of the syntax tree,
NOTE CONF
and it will interpret it.
And I've already got an executor that works on variable
NOTE CONF
assignments.
So ultimately, what I'm wanting this to do is to
NOTE CONF
get down to this part of the tree and call
execute on it, uh, which is actually the same as
NOTE CONF
just calling execute on this part of the tree, right?
Cos that block statement is actually just a list of
NOTE CONF
those cool.
So, really, Ultimately, the important thing here is to call
NOTE CONF
execute on this part of the tree.
Well, maybe, but, um because, actually, my condition is gonna
NOTE CONF
come up false in this one.
So the other alternative, ultimately, is that I'm gonna call
NOTE CONF
execute on this part of the tree.
All right, So depending on the condition, I'm gonna call
NOTE CONF
execute on one part of the tree or the other,
so I might start to write that down as code,
NOTE CONF
just as and unsurprisingly, an if in locks turns into
an if in Java, if something execute, then branch, uh,
NOTE CONF
execute branch.
So that's dealt with that.
NOTE CONF
I mean, that's really what That's all I gotta do.
So my only job now is to make sure that
NOTE CONF
I do the right thing here.
And this here again is an expression abstract syntax, tree
NOTE CONF
node, right expression, abstract syntax.
Tree nodes can be turned from locks, expressions into Java
NOTE CONF
values with another function.
I have evaluate.
NOTE CONF
So as long as I evaluate that whole thing as
a big chunk, I'll get back some Java value very
NOTE CONF
good.
So that says condition in there Evaluate condition.
NOTE CONF
So that's what we're thinking we're going to find when
we go through the text.
NOTE CONF
Let's have a look.
So we've passed it.
NOTE CONF
Um, he talks about the dangling else here, which I'll
come back to.
NOTE CONF
But having gone from scratch ourselves and thought, What are
we expecting the interpreter to look like?
NOTE CONF
Let's use the actual interpreter.
You go.
NOTE CONF
It looks like exactly what I suggested.
It says if I'm visiting a new statement, evaluate the
NOTE CONF
condition and then use that to decide if I execute
the then branch or you scratch and because I'm doing
NOTE CONF
code here, I realise I've got to do a few
other little checks.
NOTE CONF
Don't do this one.
If it's not, that obviously won't work.
NOTE CONF
And I remember from Bracket before that evaluate always returns
an object, and I'd already worked out which of my
NOTE CONF
objects were gonna be true.
But true and which ones are going to be false,
NOTE CONF
as this function called is true.
So I'm using that one again from before, and obviously
NOTE CONF
true comes up.
True false comes up true, but also inside things like
NOTE CONF
a empty string comes up true numbers and because this
is a statement, it doesn't return anything so it would
NOTE CONF
return.
Remember that we have this capital V void which is
NOTE CONF
different to lower V void that we were using along
the way.
NOTE CONF
Do you remember why this is this visitor is the
same visitor is set up for pretty printing and for
NOTE CONF
executing.
And we might set up that visitor for other.
NOTE CONF
So we had this whole visitor structure set up and
the way a visitor structure is set up is that
NOTE CONF
you don't quite know what the visitor's gonna give back.
You can define which one So some visitors might give
NOTE CONF
back strings like the blue printer one did.
Some visitors might give back objects like the expression evaluator
NOTE CONF
did and other visitors give back nothing like this one
does.
NOTE CONF
But in Java, strings, objects and lowercase V void can't
be treated synonymously lowercase V void is a very special
NOTE CONF
thing.
So the Java people introduce capital V void.
NOTE CONF
It's another kind of object and you can treat, uh,
strings, cap, capital, O objects and capital.
NOTE CONF
B boy is all the same, but that's the only
one you can use in it is.
NOTE CONF
You're stuck with a capital B boy.
But the trick with that one is you can't just
NOTE CONF
leave out your return.
You better return now or something or whatever, but it
NOTE CONF
doesn't actually get counted for anything, and that's it.
The one thing that's worth noticing here is that we've
NOTE CONF
basically just turned the equivalent block code into Java code.
And it felt like a long journey to go from
NOTE CONF
if condition execute, execute to if condition execute, execute, right,
what have we actually done here?
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna characterise what?
You're in T instead of, um, executing the code directly
NOTE CONF
after his statement.
You now call the execute function a bit different then
NOTE CONF
and you actually evaluate and departure and stuff set up
this directly.
NOTE CONF
You're on the right track.
Yes.
NOTE CONF
I mean, you're saying that your answer is correct, but
I wanna try and put it in a more deep
NOTE CONF
way there.
What I mean is that what we've actually done is
NOTE CONF
we've taken loss that we invented and turned in his
job, which has a one time.
NOTE CONF
So we really translated from locks into Java and then
this translates JDM ports.
NOTE CONF
So ultimately a bit of JB M comes out and
we didn't have to do any of the hard work
NOTE CONF
doing in the a BMJ GM just went by the
the Java.
NOTE CONF
And so we're bringing the lobster life by giving it
its Java doppelganger.
NOTE CONF
Another way to think of it.
And because locks is a lot like Java, you don't
NOTE CONF
have to make a lot of changes along the way.
But we could make differences in how locks interprets these
NOTE CONF
statements, and they all appear here.
And one of those differences is that history thing.
NOTE CONF
We define that we can change that.
We could decide in what set.
NOTE CONF
Um, I mean, I can't remember what Java does, but
in Java, I think an string counts as true.
NOTE CONF
We could decide what and stream to count as false,
and you don't have to go to our history.
NOTE CONF
Anything else would still kind of look the same because,
obviously, you know, conditions are conditions.
NOTE CONF
They're fairly fundamental, right?
Questions?
NOTE CONF
Um, actually, here's another thing to notice at this point.
Sorry, my diagram got a bit messy here, but there's
NOTE CONF
actually three sub trees under this heath.
There's the expression.
NOTE CONF
There's the D block, and there's the block.
Uh, so far, you know, every time we've had something
NOTE CONF
with more than one sub tree.
Ultimately, we just executed all the sub trees and then
NOTE CONF
done something with them.
This is the first point at which some of the
NOTE CONF
sub trees might end up not being executed.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Either one of the den branch or the S branch
are never gonna be executed in this hope.
NOTE CONF
They're just gonna stay as a tree.
The visitor's not gonna visit them, so that's important.
NOTE CONF
Because if there are run type errors in that part
of the tree, they won't ever happen.
NOTE CONF
Whereas every other thing.
We were basically just evaluating everything along the way and
NOTE CONF
then maybe doing some bookkeeping?
Uh, no, we don't actually have, uh, proper logical operators
NOTE CONF
in the language.
Yet, in case you hadn't noticed, I don't think we've
NOTE CONF
defined, equals, equals or less than equals or any of
those things.
NOTE CONF
So we go ahead and do that OK, turns out
in this language and has a higher precedence than all
NOTE CONF
rather than being at the same precedent and doing left
to right.
NOTE CONF
And so they have to be slotted in me in
the pas or whenever things have got different precedents, they
NOTE CONF
better have their own productions so that the lower precedence
one gets dispatched first and the higher dis precedence one
NOTE CONF
gets dispatched second.
So we've got both of those.
NOTE CONF
And there's a few changes to go with that.
They go under the assignment, which makes them higher than
NOTE CONF
sorry lower than any of the, um, mathematical operators.
Am I right?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Uh, so they've got those small adjustments to the Parsa
NOTE CONF
Mhm.
They don't use the binary operator on the A ST.
NOTE CONF
So this diagram I heard here wrong was wrong.
I.
NOTE CONF
I just used the binary operator for equals, but he's
decided to bring in another a ST node for logical
NOTE CONF
operators and to treat them differently to binary operators.
Why?
NOTE CONF
This is a key question.
When we're designing languages, when can we reuse what's already
NOTE CONF
there?
And when are we putting in something fundamentally new?
NOTE CONF
Why would an equals equals be fundamentally different to a
plus?
NOTE CONF
Yes, it's short circuiting.
That's right.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, and in fact, you need to only check one.
Um, something I hadn't realised until I got into implementing
NOTE CONF
programming languages.
Is that short circuiting?
NOTE CONF
So the short circuiting we're talking about here.
And when you do a plus, you always get the
NOTE CONF
left.
You always get the right.
NOTE CONF
You always add them together.
When you do an and you often do things like
NOTE CONF
OK, I'll often have some code like this, especially in
Java, where I've got some object and I want to
NOTE CONF
call a method on that object Well and I want
to call a method on that object in my condition.
NOTE CONF
Um, but obviously that's dangerous, because if a is equal
to null, then I'll get a null pointer exception when
NOTE CONF
I try and do the a dot size.
So I put in front of it an A as
NOTE CONF
long as a is not equal to null and a
dot size is greater than zero, then go ahead and
NOTE CONF
do the thing.
The reason this works in Java is because and is
NOTE CONF
short circuited, and what we mean by that is that
it's ultimately expression and expression, right?
NOTE CONF
So let's compare this to expression plus expression, so I'm
just gonna be reminded to check this again in case
NOTE CONF
nothing else.
OK, um, for expression and expression, sorry for expression plus
NOTE CONF
expression.
I absolutely have to evaluate both of them.
NOTE CONF
No choice gonna have to do it.
But for expression and expression if I did that well,
NOTE CONF
once I've done this, I might be free from doing
the other one.
NOTE CONF
Because if this one turns out to be false, I
know for sure I don't have to do the other
NOTE CONF
one, so that at first just seems like a little
benefit.
NOTE CONF
Um, Just seems like a little benefit.
But without it, this wouldn't I couldn't even write this
NOTE CONF
code, because if I didn't do the short circuiting even
if this turned out to be false, I would still
NOTE CONF
calculate this one over here.
And I'd still get my null pointer exception.
NOTE CONF
Uh, short circuiting turns out to be fundamental.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
They cer certain for speed and for logical reason, speed
and logical, Actually, just think of it as just for
NOTE CONF
logical reasons.
It does give you a speed benefit, but it turns
NOTE CONF
out without short circuiting, these languages aren't true and complete.
Um uh, So short circuiting on the end works like
NOTE CONF
that.
If you've got a false you know, you don't have
NOTE CONF
to do the other one and short circuiting on the
or works the other way.
NOTE CONF
Once you got a true you know, they don't do
the other one.
NOTE CONF
And so that's why we need a separate abstract Syntex
tree node.
NOTE CONF
Because when we hit a binary, we're definitely evaluating both
sides.
NOTE CONF
When we hit a logical we're maybe evaluating both sides
and because the interpretation has to be different, we put
NOTE CONF
a different abstract Syntex tree node in for it.
So we got our logical one now so I can
NOTE CONF
go and update my diagram.
If I wanted to, I could swap out the binary
NOTE CONF
for the logical Now, obviously for a lot of those
logical like double equals Oh, so no double equals are
NOTE CONF
still coming in as binary.
Actually, we were already doing double equals less than equal
NOTE CONF
to greater than equal were, were we?
He's only really talking about ends and os here, but
NOTE CONF
we're adding those two.
Yes, he is Mhm.
NOTE CONF
Ah, So we put the ANZ andos into the Parsa.
As you might expect, you just gotta slip them into
NOTE CONF
the right place and he uses the function.
And now the passing is not short circuited.
NOTE CONF
The passing just happens as normal.
And because you can line up oars after each other,
NOTE CONF
and they've all got the same precedent.
He uses the same trick.
NOTE CONF
He just grabs as many oars as he can in
one go and creates new logical expressions as he goes
NOTE CONF
and does the same with the ANS creates neur logical
expressions as he goes just to show you what this
NOTE CONF
is about, in case we forgot cos it's easy to
forget the way he does left associative is with this
NOTE CONF
trick of grabbing as many as I can.
So we said that or had a higher precedence than
NOTE CONF
end.
So I'll just because my handwriting is so terrible I
NOTE CONF
use or and and um so maybe I'll do true
or true or false or true.
NOTE CONF
Let's switch those out to variables X or Y or
Z or W.
NOTE CONF
Um, so if I had X or Y and Z
or W, we know that and has the higher precedents,
NOTE CONF
so it will pass this way.
But when we've got all Os, we just do left
NOTE CONF
associative, right?
So the way he does that in his compiler is
NOTE CONF
that he grabs the X, and then he got a
Y loop to grab the next one which is a
NOTE CONF
Y.
And then he bundles them X or Y.
NOTE CONF
And then he goes back around the loop and grabs
another one and bundles it with the thing that's already
NOTE CONF
there and then goes back around the loop and grabs
another one and bundles it with the one that's already
NOTE CONF
there.
And that creates his left associative.
NOTE CONF
So that's what he's doing here, right?
He's grabbing the first one and then he's going well,
NOTE CONF
as long as there's more to grab, I'll grab that
next one.
NOTE CONF
Sorry, I'll grab the next one and then I'll bundle
it up with the one I've already got.
NOTE CONF
And then I go again, grab another one and bundle
that with the one I've already got.
NOTE CONF
So that creates ultimately what you create there.
So what this looks like in the abstract syntax tree
NOTE CONF
is an ore with X on the left and Oh,
yeah, sorry.
NOTE CONF
I need a bit more space for this to create
an or with X on the left and Y on
NOTE CONF
the right.
And then that whole thing is bundled up as an
NOTE CONF
or with that on the left and Z on the
right, which is bundled up with that whole thing on
NOTE CONF
the left.
Sorry, that last one was a W.
NOTE CONF
Uh, with that on the left and W on the
right.
NOTE CONF
OK, so he's he's constructing this tree through his wild
loop, starting first at this one and then chunk, Chunk
NOTE CONF
Chunk adding them on.
OK, so visiting it is where we have to do
NOTE CONF
the short circuiting.
So if we're visiting an A type expression and the
NOTE CONF
left So, uh, the key to short circuiting is that,
uh if the left hand one is true for an
NOTE CONF
A, you just return True.
But if the left hand one is false, you have
NOTE CONF
to return whatever the value of the right is.
And then it's the opposite for an end.
NOTE CONF
So if the left hand side is false, then you
just return the left hand side.
NOTE CONF
Otherwise you have to return whatever the right hand side
is.
NOTE CONF
And so this ex this implements the short circuiting forest
with this little If so, you can see now that
NOTE CONF
we've ended up this, this translation wasn't as simple.
We didn't convert an if to an If this time
NOTE CONF
we converted a boolean operator to nested ifs.
So we are actually adding some structure in here.
NOTE CONF
Um and you can compare that to binary to see
that it's different.
NOTE CONF
And on we go questions.
Alright, So we got conditions in now let's put loops
NOTE CONF
in what extra things do we have to think about
for loops?
NOTE CONF
Well, not much.
It's largely gonna go the same well for For it's
NOTE CONF
gonna start the same way we're gonna do wild loops
because this language has wild loops and four loops.
NOTE CONF
Um, exactly the same thing.
It it declares itself with a with a keyword.
NOTE CONF
So it's very easy to add into the Parsa.
We're gonna use exactly the same form because Ys and
NOTE CONF
fours always look the same.
It was, and if so, it looked the same.
NOTE CONF
But it doesn't have three bodies, it doesn't have a
condition.
NOTE CONF
And then an analysis just got a condition in a
body.
NOTE CONF
But we make the new abstract syntax node for that.
And then we put it in our pasar and then
NOTE CONF
parsing it is actually super simple parsing it is.
Just grab the left parenthesis, grab the expression, grab the
NOTE CONF
right parenthesis.
Grab the statement, return it.
NOTE CONF
Nice.
Uh, but executing it.
NOTE CONF
What does executing a wild loop look like?
So I might do what we did before, where we
NOTE CONF
think about what we want it to look like.
We can see it right there.
NOTE CONF
But let's jump over to the to the diagram as
well.
NOTE CONF
It's always good to think ahead of what you expect,
especially with a book like this, where the answers just
NOTE CONF
presented, presented, presented.
Creating an expectation for yourself that can be met or
NOTE CONF
not is a good one.
So I'm gonna do YX greater than zero X equals
NOTE CONF
X minus one.
OK, so I'm expecting this much was clear out of
NOTE CONF
that.
I'm hoping that this is gonna pass into a while
NOTE CONF
and the whale's got a condition and a body, and
the condition is gonna be the well that's a binary
NOTE CONF
still, And the binary is gonna have a left and
a right and the left is going to be the
NOTE CONF
variable X and the right is gonna be the literal
zero should be getting bored of writing out abstract syntax
NOTE CONF
trees.
But that means we know what we're doing.
NOTE CONF
And then the body is a block statement again because
it's got those curly braces and it's got a list.
NOTE CONF
And again, the block statement has just a single statement
inside it, which is again an assignment statement.
NOTE CONF
And the assignment statement always has a token and an
expression.
NOTE CONF
And so the token is the sorry.
That's not a token.
NOTE CONF
That's a expression.
Actually, Assignment puts expression on the left, but then does
NOTE CONF
that if you recall assignment, puts expression on the left,
but then does a trick to make sure you've used
NOTE CONF
an expression that can be assigned to uh, yeah, so
that's expression one and expression two.
NOTE CONF
that turns out to be a variable, which turns out
to be an X.
NOTE CONF
And the expression two, which is the X minus one,
turns out to be another binary operator.
NOTE CONF
This time it's minus Sorry.
I left out the, um token on this one, which
NOTE CONF
was greater than the token on.
This one is minus and the left is the V
NOTE CONF
X, and the right is the literal one.
OK, so that's what we're expecting that to turn into
NOTE CONF
as an abstract syntax tree node.
So what we're hoping for, I guess, is that we're
NOTE CONF
gonna to evaluate this wild loop.
We're probably gonna first evaluate all of this.
NOTE CONF
And then if that's true, we'll evaluate this.
Sorry, we will execute this and then we'll go and
NOTE CONF
do that again and again and again.
OK, so that, uh, that's actually just, uh, that's just
NOTE CONF
a wild loop in Java.
So it'll be while that whole thing executes to true.
NOTE CONF
So evaluates the true execute this whole thing.
Alright, cool.
NOTE CONF
Sounds like that's another simple translation just into the Java.
We just gotta make sure we put our evaluates and
NOTE CONF
our, um executes in the right place and that's exactly
what we get.
NOTE CONF
We get the wild loop that evaluates the condition, uses
the same as truth the trick and then executes the
NOTE CONF
body, executes the money.
And so this execution of the body has to change
NOTE CONF
the environment before this one will ever get false.
But that's what we expect.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
So that one was exactly like an F.
NOTE CONF
And that might help you realise that a wild statement
is just an if that revisits itself.
NOTE CONF
If you didn't already realise that Alright, Last of all,
we are going to do four loops.
NOTE CONF
Um, we could do four lips from scratch, but they
choose not to.
NOTE CONF
In the book, he chooses to do four loops as
a syntactic sugar, and what we mean by that is
NOTE CONF
that we we convert the four loop into an equivalent
Y loop and then just move on cos then we
NOTE CONF
don't have to write an interpreter for the for loop,
we only have to write the Parsa.
NOTE CONF
And if the pars are, instead of spitting out a
special new node we made up for four loops, it
NOTE CONF
spits out the appropriate while loop.
Nothing else has to change in the compiler for the
NOTE CONF
interpreter.
So we do need the Parsa, and so that goes
NOTE CONF
in and in this one it to make it match
best with C.
NOTE CONF
He's done a little bit of stuff here in in
what can go into the for loop, he said.
NOTE CONF
You can either have a variable declaration or you can
have an expression statement in here, Um, but the only
NOTE CONF
thing that can go there is a possible expression.
Then there has to be a semicolon, then a possible
NOTE CONF
expression.
Then there has to be a closed parentheses, and then
NOTE CONF
the statement, which is probably a block statement.
So he implements that as Well, um, he's also very
NOTE CONF
precise about exactly what a four loop is again.
We're learning four loops, but you already know it.
NOTE CONF
But the precision is coming up.
You know, we're gonna initialise her on the four loop
NOTE CONF
that's executed exactly once before.
Anything else then?
NOTE CONF
The condition which tells you where the loop goes around.
And then the last clause, which is an increment, Which
NOTE CONF
for us in our heads, we've always just thought of
as being the last thing to happen in the loop.
NOTE CONF
But here in locks is very precisely gonna be the
last thing that happens in a loop.
NOTE CONF
Because locks doesn't execute four loops directly, it converts them
into one of these.
NOTE CONF
Now, I really want to talk about why this works
in locks when it might not elsewhere and why we
NOTE CONF
need those extra curly braces.
So I'm gonna write that up now before it goes
NOTE CONF
off the screen.
OK, so there's a sense in which what we're doing
NOTE CONF
is super boring and obvious, But there are little corner
things that I really want you to get.
NOTE CONF
So I don't mind being boring and obvious till those
other things stand out.
NOTE CONF
So follow along follow along.
There's something key here that you might miss this for.
NOTE CONF
Loop and this Y loop are equivalent and you should
be perfectly comfortable with that.
NOTE CONF
You should have done these conversions yourselves many times in
the past.
NOTE CONF
No other Sheikh.
Tell me, have you done these conversions many times in
NOTE CONF
the past.
Ah, but you didn't actually do this conversion when you
NOTE CONF
converted a four loop to a wild loop.
Previously, you converted it to This is what you really
NOTE CONF
did when you did it.
You did?
NOTE CONF
Well, it's the initialise and then the wow with the
condition and then the body, and then the increase.
NOTE CONF
That's not the same.
What's different?
NOTE CONF
Find the difference.
Yeah, it's great.
NOTE CONF
Yes, two brackets.
These two brackets are the difference.
NOTE CONF
So in your mind, you probably always converted it like
this.
NOTE CONF
But the real explicitly correct way to do it is
to put all of that inside its own statement Block.
NOTE CONF
Why?
Because statement blocks introduce a new scope.
NOTE CONF
And that means that the eye here exists inside that
statement block and does not exist outside that statement block
NOTE CONF
so that if our code had done, I equals zero
like this immediately afterwards.
NOTE CONF
Our naive translation would break because it would also have
an I equals zero and it would be the same
NOTE CONF
eye, No good.
In a real translation, the I equals zero under here
NOTE CONF
either has to be an error or it has to
refer to some global I.
NOTE CONF
So our subtlety in the translation brings the semantics just
perfectly for us that we jump into a new statement
NOTE CONF
block so that the initialise is declaring that in a
totally fresh environment.
NOTE CONF
Then all the code executes.
Then we back off out of the statement block to
NOTE CONF
make that environment disappear.
The other thing I want you to say about this
NOTE CONF
is this is a really nice design.
We've now got two big wins from having statement blocks
NOTE CONF
in our language.
You might never have thought of statement blocks.
NOTE CONF
You probably never wrote code that just started with a
curly brace for no good reason.
NOTE CONF
Um, even if your language supported it.
But we've now got two good reasons to like, statement
NOTE CONF
blocks one.
These are good reasons.
NOTE CONF
So we'll use the sparkly thing.
We got that nice syntax for the conditionals and the
NOTE CONF
loops where we just said, if condition statement and the
statement could be a single statement or multiple statements and
NOTE CONF
we didn't have to think about it.
And secondly, we can always get a fresh scope whenever
NOTE CONF
we need one.
Oh simple.
NOTE CONF
OK, so this is the actual, um, translation.
But again, to understand the code you're gonna see, I
NOTE CONF
think seeing it as a piece of code is in
like we go.
NOTE CONF
OK, I understand that.
But when you go to look at the sugar translation
NOTE CONF
that he does, you'll probably be confused unless you've always
got already got a picture of the abstract syntax tree
NOTE CONF
cos that's what he's building.
He's not building a string programme when he converts it.
NOTE CONF
He's PA at the time that he's parsing it.
He's building the abstract syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
So if we make the abstract syntax tree for this
wall loop on the right, we're getting the abstract syntax
NOTE CONF
tree that we wanna create when we pass the thing
on the left.
NOTE CONF
So let's draw out what that looks like.
So I'm drawing the axe sex tree for the Wi
NOTE CONF
Loop here, so that's a block statement with a single
thing in it.
NOTE CONF
I don't have multiple things in it.
Sorry.
NOTE CONF
It's a block statement with multiple things in it.
So how am I gonna do those?
NOTE CONF
I'll do those vertically, because this is a list of
things.
NOTE CONF
So the first one is an ass is a variable
declaration, which, in this case, does I and zero.
NOTE CONF
The second thing is a wild loop, and the wall
loop has a condition, which, in this case, is the
NOTE CONF
binary.
Well, I'll just leave it like this because this is
NOTE CONF
walk in a day and a body.
Ah, well, no, it's not just a body here, is
NOTE CONF
it?
Because the wall loop it was the original body with
NOTE CONF
another statement jammed next to it.
So I've gotta build myself another block statement here so
NOTE CONF
I can stick them together.
And the first thing in that block statement is the
NOTE CONF
body.
And the second thing in that block statement is the
NOTE CONF
I equals I plus one.
So this is the little structure I'm having to build
NOTE CONF
when I make my for and I've got two block
statements in there that weren't there before.
NOTE CONF
This body is probably a block statement as well.
But once I see that, I should be more comfortable
NOTE CONF
with what I'm about to see in the code.
Let's go look at it.
NOTE CONF
Oh, and he's gonna build it from the bottom up
Because you always do that.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
To the P.
NOTE CONF
Do you go back?
So it was question.
NOTE CONF
So you get the books in the left up and
bottom, Right?
NOTE CONF
Right.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
And if we in the bottom, right?
Right.
NOTE CONF
Did you go big, uh, into the blue box of
I?
NOTE CONF
I You don't have to, because the wire loop is
already built to to do all of this and then
NOTE CONF
go back and then do all of this and then
go back and then do this and all of that.
NOTE CONF
We don't have to include that in.
That's included in the semantics of the wi or the
NOTE CONF
interpretation of the wire, which we just wrote.
Yeah, good question.
NOTE CONF
Thank you.
OK, so he passes it here, which is interesting enough,
NOTE CONF
but I wanted to get to the evaluation because of
what we just talked about.
NOTE CONF
Oh, where to go?
Yep.
NOTE CONF
So after passing it first he builds the new body,
which is a block statement, the first part of which
NOTE CONF
is the body the second part of which is the
increment.
NOTE CONF
So he's built that little bottom right part of my
diagram and called it body.
NOTE CONF
Then he's built the wild statement and attached the two
parts, the condition which was already passed and the body
NOTE CONF
that he just built.
So now he's built a bit more up towards the
NOTE CONF
from the bottom, right upwards.
And then he's put that in another statement block where
NOTE CONF
the first line is the initialise that he already passed.
And the second part is that wall loop we just
NOTE CONF
created.
And he's got all these, uh, all these hidden under,
NOTE CONF
um ifs in case some of those parts of that
fall loop weren't in there, right?
NOTE CONF
So the first thing he's done af after he pauses
it.
NOTE CONF
So this is the reason I left these here, right?
Because as you pause this, this one gets the name
NOTE CONF
increment.
So let's cut these out just during the parsing.
NOTE CONF
This gets the name initialise condition.
Thank you.
NOTE CONF
Bye.
And so, the very first thing, if you go back
NOTE CONF
and look at the code yourself, the very first thing
he does is he builds.
NOTE CONF
Uh huh.
He builds this block statement out of those two parts,
NOTE CONF
and then he connects it to that part.
So that's step one.
NOTE CONF
That's Step two.
And then he connects it completely and sit three.
NOTE CONF
And so that's the the, um, the syntactic sugar.
We've gone from passing a for loop to generating stuff
NOTE CONF
we already have in the language.
I noticed it wasn't just a simple while loop.
NOTE CONF
We had to do some stuff here to make sure
the semantics pa matched perfectly.
NOTE CONF
Um, but we've built from the passing phase something that's
already in the language, so no more work required on
NOTE CONF
the interpreter.
Done.
NOTE CONF
So we've now seen two types of syntactic sugar, the
one I introduced via the assessment, which was the PA
NOTE CONF
the PA scanning level, or passing level syntactic sugar.
I guess that was scanning level syntactic sugar, and now
NOTE CONF
it's in passing level syntactic sugar.
We've got to go a bit deeper into the Parsa
NOTE CONF
to work out how the sugar works, but again, we
don't have to add another.
NOTE CONF
We don't have to add something to our a ST,
and we don't have to add something to our interpreter.
NOTE CONF
Now I want to talk a little bit about the
core language, so he doesn't mention this in the book,
NOTE CONF
but I think it's key to understanding what's going on.
Modern compiler and interpreter writers will almost always express their
NOTE CONF
work in terms of, um, user basing language, core language
and targeting.
NOTE CONF
And we saw this on the map.
The input languages we have the top of the mountain
NOTE CONF
have the Alpha name we talk.
The way of recall language is something that trying to
NOTE CONF
sit at the top of the mountain.
And it's the term you'll hear people use when they
NOTE CONF
talk about syntactic sugar, you can hear it's the term
you'll hear people use when they talk about syntactic sugar.
NOTE CONF
You'll say this source language construct gets turned into this
core language.
NOTE CONF
Construct.
Um, what?
NOTE CONF
I want you to get your head around at this
point?
NOTE CONF
Well, someone tell me which Java class or classes represents
my core language.
NOTE CONF
I can only get one of them on the screen
at a time.
NOTE CONF
It's expression dot Java and statement dot java.
That's where my core language is completely contained.
NOTE CONF
So in my source language, I had I think of
things like four Loops and Y loops and if statements
NOTE CONF
and I think of things like variable declarations and I
but in my core language, I think of less of
NOTE CONF
them, only one less at this point.
But it's one less, I think of variable Declaration.
NOTE CONF
Well, actually, you know, in the source language, I think
of pluses and minuses, and I think of R's and
NOTE CONF
NS.
But in the core language, I think of binary operators,
NOTE CONF
unary operators and logical operators.
I've reduced the number of concepts and in the source
NOTE CONF
language, I think of, if while and four but in
the core language, I only think of if and why.
NOTE CONF
OK, so the a ST, which is at the top
of that mountain in the original diagram, is our core
NOTE CONF
language.
Um, and the Fulmer and everything else kind of revolves.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
And that's the modern way to write interpreters to get
NOTE CONF
that core language right.
The core language only needs to support the source language
NOTE CONF
and be able to be translated into the back end
language.
NOTE CONF
And then you can use whatever tricks you want to
get your source language into your core language, and you'll
NOTE CONF
find yourself when you're expressing things to your user.
expressing them to the user in terms of the core
NOTE CONF
language.
OK, so let's think about some other core languages that
NOTE CONF
we know of, uh well, Scala, for example.
Its core language is Java.
NOTE CONF
So whenever you're thinking of Scala, you're always thinking of
the Java that it interprets into Java itself.
NOTE CONF
Didn't used to have a core.
Java was Java.
NOTE CONF
They added extra features.
They've been smart enough to add a lot of them
NOTE CONF
as syntactic sugar so that some features from source Java
don't exist in core Java anymore.
NOTE CONF
What's the best example of that?
You know of generics, right?
NOTE CONF
When you programme generics in Java, you have to think
not just about the source language construct, but the core
NOTE CONF
language construct.
It gets converted into via type easer.
NOTE CONF
And if you've done generics, you weren't able to do
generics unless you knew both right?
NOTE CONF
So it's the trade off with syntactic sugar, your user
has to know the source language and the core language.
NOTE CONF
But the win is that the core language is, hopefully
such a simple thing.
NOTE CONF
Uh, that they it's actually a bit of a a
comfort to say Oh, look, I know what this complicated
NOTE CONF
source language feature is because I think of it in
terms of this simpler underlying core language.
NOTE CONF
Uh, now, next week, we're going hog wild on that
by looking at closure cos closure is a language, and
NOTE CONF
they're just like, bugger it.
You've just got the core language, and it's the coolest
NOTE CONF
core language ever.
And you can work out your own syntactic sugar from
NOTE CONF
there.
Um, but I was a little bit like that as
NOTE CONF
well.
Ok, let's check to see that.
NOTE CONF
We've covered everything we need to cover.
Oh, no.
NOTE CONF
There was some bits here I hadn't done.
Uh, that's for the workshop, So I'll let you read
NOTE CONF
that yourself.
Please do read this challenge section.
NOTE CONF
There's a workshop question related to it.
This challenge section I don't want to leave that for
NOTE CONF
you to think about, not challenge section um, design note.
So the bit we didn't talk about yet is exactly
NOTE CONF
how the four loop gets passed.
He's He's slightly interesting in the way he passes the
NOTE CONF
for loop because each section is optional and he wants
to build it up correctly.
NOTE CONF
So it's probably worth just touching on how it gets
done.
NOTE CONF
Consumes lab parenthesis straight away, obviously, then consumes an initialise.
But if no now I'm confused who tries to get
NOTE CONF
an initialise?
But if he finds a semicolon instead, the initialise must
NOTE CONF
have been null.
Oh, no, he just sets up the initialise, so he
NOTE CONF
hasn't tried to consume it yet, So he's at the
start of the left parenthesis.
NOTE CONF
Now you can, in this language, put four parenthesis, semicolon,
semicolon, close parenthesis That's valid.
NOTE CONF
That's an infinite loop that goes forever, right?
That's standard in C to write your infinite loops that
NOTE CONF
way.
So he's wanting to support that version of A for
NOTE CONF
loop.
I never would stuff that my users can just write
NOTE CONF
a wild trip.
Um, so he tries to.
NOTE CONF
He's when he's trying to pause the initialise first.
He has to check.
NOTE CONF
Is there a semicolon?
If so, my initialises No.
NOTE CONF
Is there a V that means they're doing a variable
declaration in here.
NOTE CONF
Otherwise, they're just doing a standard expression statement because you
can you can put your initialise doesn't have to create
NOTE CONF
a new area.
So he's got to check each of those three and
NOTE CONF
then he gets his initialise.
Once he's got his initialise.
NOTE CONF
What's next, right?
So he pulled the initialise.
NOTE CONF
He's going right now.
I gotta check there might or might not be a
NOTE CONF
condition, so I'll set up the condition.
If there's a semicolon, I'm done.
NOTE CONF
If there's not a semicolon, I can pause another expression,
and that goes in the condition.
NOTE CONF
There's definitely gonna be a semicolon after.
And then again, the same trick with the the, uh,
NOTE CONF
increment there might or might not be an increment, so
I'll set it up as not being there.
NOTE CONF
If there's no right parenthesis, then good, I'm the next
thing's not a right parenthesis.
NOTE CONF
Then I'm good to go.
I can grab my initial, uh, my, uh increment.
NOTE CONF
But if it is, I'll just skip right past and
put a null in for the increment.
NOTE CONF
And then it's much easier just to pull the body.
And as he goes, OK, so that gets to the
NOTE CONF
He just returns buddy here, which is not true.
He doesn't really return, buddy.
NOTE CONF
There's all this code in between we're about to see.
So then, once he's grabbed all those parts, he starts
NOTE CONF
building up that term we saw so that he can
return that term instead of returning the new If not,
NOTE CONF
it could be a fun, uh, exercise to redo this.
Not with syntactic sugar to make yourself, uh, for nod
NOTE CONF
in your a ST and work out what that would
look like and what interpreting that would look like.
NOTE CONF
Um, I surprisingly, that would be a good for the
assignment, because that's what I ask you to do in
NOTE CONF
the assignment.
We make up another kind of loop that's a bit
NOTE CONF
like a for loop.
Um, you actually have the decision to make when you
NOTE CONF
do the assignment, whether you want to do it as
syntactic sugar or you want to do it from scratch.
NOTE CONF
Um, the assignment is designed so that one of those
is a bad choice.
NOTE CONF
So think ahead, sit down and think, Should I do
this as syntactic sugar?
NOTE CONF
What would it look like if I did it as
syntactic sugar?
NOTE CONF
If that's easy, that's my path.
If that's not easy, that's not my path.
NOTE CONF
And those who don't think ahead and just pick one
and go ahead would just hit a dead end and
NOTE CONF
have to start again.
OK, any other questions?
NOTE CONF
Nope, nope.
Nope.
NOTE CONF
Alright.
Well, then, that's us.
NOTE CONF
for the day.
Thank you very much.
NOTE CONF
I should see you around.
Oh, and Oh, sorry.
NOTE CONF
The last thing to announce to say, for those who
are unaware, I don't know if I posted it on
NOTE CONF
the forums yet, but if you've got the three o'clock
class tomorrow, Three o'clock, practical tomorrow.
NOTE CONF
That was with Jess.
Jess is no longer with us.
NOTE CONF
She works for Jeff Bezos.
Now, um, you have, uh, the one for, uh, Lachlan
NOTE CONF
who's taken over that class.
So just keep an eye for him.
NOTE CONF
Jess, I think I messed up.
Mhm.
NOTE CONF
I think I messed up between 1130 1230.
I was trying to get the students to come here
NOTE CONF
at 1130 to do their makeup exam because I was
sick of them telling me I can't come to that
NOTE CONF
time.
I can't come to that time.
NOTE CONF
So I'm, like, do it to the lecture time.
Uh, you can You'll be able to go to that
NOTE CONF
time, and, uh